turning now to a scary story out of the
bahamas where investigators are
searching for answers after three
american tourists died in their hotel
rooms and another had to be airlifted to
a hospital all four victims were staying
at the sandals emerald bay resort in
great exuma health officials there have
not determined what caused the deaths
but say foul foul play rather is not
suspected the u.s state department says
it is closely monitoring the
investigation and our manuel bajorkas
has more
there were some signs of individuals
presenting to the clinic with nausea
vomiting and some symptoms the bahamas
health minister says it all began
thursday night two american tourists at
the sandals emerald bay resort
complained they were feeling ill and
were treated at a local medical facility
the next morning the couple was found
dead in their resort villa the man
police say was slumped against a wall
the woman was on their bed both showed
signs of convulsion
minutes earlier police had found another
man dead on the floor of his villa abc
news reports it was birmingham alabama
resident vincent ciarrella and that his
wife donna survived after experiencing
severe swelling and paralysis
she was airlifted to princess margaret
hospital in the capital nassau about a
30 minute flight away now health
officials are waiting on autopsy reports
to determine what caused the tourists
mysterious deaths hopefully nothing's
going to happen to us jason toth and
sydney rosenquist arrived at the sandals
resort for their honeymoon one day after
the victims bodies were found it
definitely gives me a cause for concern
just because you want to know what
happened it's certainly very irregular
as a general rule cbs news medical
contributor dr david agus says it's
important to have access to your health
records when you travel and to listen to
your body if you start to feel ill and
it's not getting better that you go to
an emergency room wherever you are and
if the treatment doesn't work go back to
that emergency room for cbs mornings i'm
manuel bojorquez
we should point out we did reach out to
sandals for comment they told us they
followed protocol alerting medical
personnel and local law enforcement as
soon as they were aware of the health
emergencies they also say they're now
actively working in support of the
investigation it's a very tragic story
this is a highlight of people's lives
and ends up being the end of it yeah
tragic and disturbing you know it's one
of those places that my wife and i love
to visit um and like you said people
want to go to relax and enjoy themselves
before they return back home absolutely
their life ends there yeah all right